in this lesson we're going to talk about
the one-to-one property of exponents so
what is the one-to-one property of
exponents well
what you want is when you have the same
base okay both raised to a power if the
bases are the same and you have an
equation like this then the exponents
must be the same so what you can do is
you can then set the exponents equal and
solve so we're gonna go through a couple
examples here see if you can pause the
video and do them on your own and we'll
go through them together the first one
it says four to the two x minus three
equals one-half to the fifth power solve
for x
okay so what you want to do here is you
can see right now the bases are not the
same but when you look at one half and
four you know probably what jumps out at
you is that they both
could be transformed into base two so
we're going to do here 4 is really like
2 squared
right
okay all raised to the 2x minus 3 and
one half is really 2 to the negative 1
all raised to the power of 5.
now when you have a power to a power
what do you do well you multiply the
exponents so this is going to be 2 to
the 4x minus 6
equals 2 to the negative 5th
now you can see we have the same base
both base 2 so we can set the powers
equal to each other so 4x minus 6 equals
negative 5 let's add 6 to both sides
we've got 4x equals 1 divide by 4 right
and x equals 1 4.
so that's how you can do this type of
problem the other way to do it is you
could take the multiple choice answers
of course and put them in for x and you
know keep checking back and forth to see
if they're equivalent but this is pretty
quick method as well if you can
recognize that they have the same base
and then you can set the powers equal so
example number two see if you can do
this one
and we'll go through together so square
root of three
is actually three to the one half power
okay because the numerator is the power
the denominator is the root so the
square root is really like the one-half
power
okay all raised to the 3x and 9 is
actually 3 squared
okay and this is raised to the 2x minus
5 power so what we have here is we have
a power to a power okay so remember we
want to multiply so this is going to be
3 to the 3 halves x equals 3 to the 4x
minus 10 okay now you can see we have
the same base both base 3 we can set the
powers equal we've got 3 halves x
equals 4x minus 10. and what you could
do if you want is just to clear the
denominators by multiplying everything
by 2 so that'll clear this denominator
here and give us 3x
equals
8x minus 20.
okay so now all we have to do is let's
see subtract 8x from both sides
okay so that gives us let's see negative
five x equals negative twenty so that
means that x equals positive four if we
divide both sides by negative five and
again you can check your answer if you
put it back in you know you can verify
that those are going to be
equivalent
so the main idea in this lesson is just
the one-to-one property of exponents get
the bases the same set the powers equal
and you got it i'll see in the next
lesson